[Music]
DevOps methodologies DevOps has become a
common buzzword in IT circles this video
will help I T professionals get more
familiar with and learn the
methodologies associated with DevOps
we will examine a number of DevOps
practices common in the IT world and
highlight those that are most popular as
well as give pros and cons to each
approach infrastructure as code the
first prerequisite of modern DevOps
methodology is infrastructure as code I
a see in early IT implementations the
VMware admin would log in to V Center
and simply clone a standard template to
create a new virtual machine this manual
process was acceptable for the creation
of one or two virtual images but could
not scale to a modern implementation
that involves managing hundreds of VMs
this led to the development of
infrastructure as code or programmable
infrastructure and is the way that most
companies today provision their
infrastructure whether it be virtual
machines or containers IAC is at the
heart of current DevOps implementation
and allows for the provisioning
management and update of infrastructure
each of the configuration management
tools have domain-specific language for
example puppet chef and terraform since
these tools and their output in effect
represent the working states of our
infrastructure it allows us to view and
treat our infrastructure as if it's code
for example in the design and release
cycles and maintenance and versioning
IAC features and advantages so then what
are the features and benefits of
treating our infrastructure as code the
first advantage is that it makes our
infrastructure version about for
instance perhaps we need to roll back
our infrastructure to a previous state
due to a loading issue since the
infrastructure is maintained in our VCS
system we simply select the relevant
release by date or version and deploy
that configuration we can also use the
VCS system to see the result of
incremental changes to infrastructure
over time this can be a powerful way to
diagnose problems the configuration is
testable just as we test other software
before we deploy it our infrastructure
code may be sandboxed and tested before
deployment its repeatable since the
infrastructure is implemented as code we
can efficiently replicate any
infrastructure element in an accurate
and scalable way whether it is one or a
thousand elements they will all be
deployed identically additionally this
allows for parallel deployment for
instance if one element or of
infrastructure takes 15 minutes to
deploy a thousand would take over 250
hours however since we have implemented
our infrastructure as code we may take
advantage of multiple physical resources
cores machines etc so that our
provisioning time will be the same
regardless of scale this is one of the
most important features of IAC
popular IAC tools chef this is one of
the most popular tools for
infrastructure as code and configuration
management puppet the biggest competitor
of chef is puppet puppet was actually in
the marketplace earlier than chef but
these two offerings comprise the largest
share of the market ansible this is
actually owned by Red Hat it is a
comparatively new product but has gained
immense popularity in the last couple of
months and is in fact almost as popular
as chef and puppet and is gaining in
market share saltstack has many robust
features and many companies have
standardized on it also worth mentioning
our powershell DSC cfengine Bladelogic
and other various tools however the
first four are probably the most widely
adopted infrastructure and configuration
management tools at this time working
towards CI CD pipeline the second
principle of current DevOps methodology
is to be constantly working towards a CI
CD pipeline where CI CD stands for
continuous integration continuous
delivery this principle is central to
DevOps the goal is to achieve a pipeline
where development changes move from
phase to phase in a seamless manner
through a series of triggers and
feedback loops each phase is continuous
with feedback until the trigger
conditions are met only then when all
contingencies are met can the next phase
be initiated additionally each stage is
automated such that for instance when a
change is entered into the VCS system
this either initiates a feedback
condition or automatically triggers a
build and test cycle there are various
automation tools available to implement
the CI pipeline the most popular by far
is Jenkins but others like bamboo
teamcity and circles CI are common as
well each trigger point can be automated
such that we have automated builds
automated testing automated deployments
automated provisioning etc the key point
here is to implement a pipeline that is
integrated seamless and
error-free so then the entire cycle from
the developer writing code to deployment
is known as the CIC D pipeline three
buzzwords for CI CD that we will hear
are continuous integration continuous
delivery and continuous deployment there
is a small but significant difference
between continuous delivery and
continuous deployment which we will want
to highlight here the continuous
integration phase is the same for both
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment in both models the developers
commit their changes and this initiates
a build and test cycle that ultimately
triggers the next phase in the pipeline
however if you look at the top pipeline
labeled continuous delivery the deploy
to production box is orange this is to
point out the fact that the continuous
delivery model follows the pre-arranged
release cycle of the software in other
words the changes are pushed out
manually when the next software release
occurs for example annually with
continuous deployment the changes are
pushed out automatically as soon as they
trigger the smoke test phase this
continuous deployment model makes
changes available immediately throughout
the system without respect to the
software release cycle deployments and
downtime another key feature of modern
DevOps is the ability to deploy without
downtime there are a few different
deployment strategies that we can follow
to minimize downtime they are rolling
updates blue/green deployments canary
deployments let's look at each one to
see how they compare rolling deployments
rolling deployments divides the server
form into groups known as subsets where
each subset will be updated in turn
while the other subsets remain active so
for example if we had 100 servers we
might make four subsets of 25 servers
apiece now we can batch update the first
subset of 25 while the remaining 75
servers are still actively serving the
application to end
users now we can restart the first
subset and continue the process with the
next subset and still maintain 75
servers active through the entire
deployment using loading analysis in
tandem with rolling deployments we may
be able to tune the subsets and
eliminate downtime completely the next
strategy is blue grain also known as a/b
deployments this methodology requires
two identical Hardware environments this
means that the server's hosts networking
components storage components all have
to be identical and configured the same
one environment is actively serving the
user base while the second environment
is updated then at some point the
passive environment is activated and the
user base is served from the updated
environment the third method of
deployment is known as canary deployment
this methodology has become extremely
popular recently and is used by giants
like Amazon and Netflix with canary
development only a small subset of
servers is updated with the changes if
the changes caused no problems the
changes are rolled out further and
monitored again this cycle continues
until the entire user base is included
at any time in the process if problems
are identified the updates can be rolled
back this enables two very powerful
strategies the first is performance and
quality testing to a defined subset of
users the second use case is multi
variant testing here there may be some
uncertainty as to which feature set best
serves a user base the canary method
allows the software producer to test the
variant feature sets on defined subsets
of the user group to determine
acceptability once the determination is
made the final version can be deployed
to all users moving towards
microservices on containers the next key
to modern DevOps practice is the move
towards microservices in traditional
monolithic software development a single
virtual machine would be dedicated to
serving in application however with the
advent of micro services using an entire
virtual machine to deploy a micro
service is costly from a resource as
well as a performance standpoint
companies today are using containers for
their micro services deployments
containers have completely changed the
way we deploy manage and maintain our
applications this is why all major cloud
service providers such as AWS Asia and
Google cloud have integrated docker and
provide containers as a service
let's take a look at some of the
benefits of containers agility if you
use containers in your software
deployment they will become more agile
by that we mean you can use containers
to deploy applications by
compartmentalizing you can accelerate
application development test and
deployment package dependencies means
you can deploy anywhere containers suit
the continuous deployment methodology
and enable build ship and run
consistency
consistency is the key to successful
releases in the monolithic deployment
methodology environmental
inconsistencies are the main cause of
failed deployments small differences
between the dev and tests and deployment
environments become major roadblocks to
a successful deployment containers
remove this roadblock by packaging all
dependencies utility containers start
and run much more quickly than virtual
machines one second as opposed to one or
two minutes or even more for a virtual
machine in particular for small test
cases containers are ideal containers
were designed to support the
micro-services architecture
breaking the silos the final principle
of DevOps is breaking the silos when we
talk about having an efficient CI CD
pipeline we are presuming that we have
collaboration this means that developers
testers operations personnel anyone who
is a business stakeholder in your
application should be working together
however in large projects and large
organizations this is rarely the case
the traditional team structure where
teams are siloed by development
operations networking storage etc will
not work efficiently in a modern DevOps
environment Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos
addresses this with a very simple
concept known as the to pizza rule this
rule simply states that no team or
meeting should be larger than the number
of people that can be fed by two pizzas
this would mean about ten to twelve
people in a single team small teams are
more productive more easily managed and
have more ownership of the application
the benefits of the small team are one
team is involved end to end
this means that one team has the entire
responsibility for the application or
micro service this means that one team
will manage the micro service through
all cycles of the CI CD pipeline
development testing deployment
maintenance and support because of this
the focus is on problem solving to
achieve a business goal in a siloed
approach the focus is on making sure the
problem is not because of the silo since
the agile team has end-to-end
responsibility the focus is to fix the
problem not fix the blame since blame is
not the issue focus is maintained on the
issue this immediately reduces
stonewalling and improves productivity
with total responsibility focus downtime
is drastically reduced and the dreaded
3:00 a.m. call becomes an endangered
species a lower support load means the
team can focus on more productive things
like new features the to pizza rule fail
forward always be ready for feedback
systems fail people make mistakes
somebody once said if you design a
server allowing that it will have
outages then those outages will never
occur in other words we fail our way to
success by incorporating feedback from
the failure into our process and fixing
the problem take personal responsibility
don't blame anyone create success from
failure by sharing what you learned each
failure includes lessons for success
share them start immediately when
someone is learning to ride a bike and
they fall their parent puts them back on
the bike right away they soon forget
about their failure when they were
zooming down the road don't do it alone
No cultivate and orchestrate your
network we succeed as a team these then
are some of the key principles and
practices of the modern DevOps
environment it is by no means and a
exhaustive list but they do represent a
list of common practices that are being
implemented by major organizations
across the globe and have been proved
useful in real environments thank you
for your time and thank you for
listening hey once become an expert in
cloud computing then subscribe to
simpler Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here